do you ever wonder what would happen if
demon moons fought against each other in
blood battles how would these fights
play out and is there a demon who'd
managed to climb through the ranks and
become the new upper Moon one well after
researching and rereading manga many
times I figured out exactly what would
happen and some of these outcomes you
are definitely not expecting for example
check out this battle where guitero and
Doki fight against Yoko judging by the
rank of the Demons it is logical to
think that gyoko would win here since he
has a higher rank however it's not that
straightforward and it actually be
really hard for gyoko to win this one
yutoro and daki are the only upper moons
that fight together which would already
make it pretty hard for gyoko as he'd
have to keep track of two opponents
simultaneously moreover the strength
difference between futuro and gyoko
doesn't seem to be that big as both
demons dominated their fights against
hashira and only lost due to Demon
Slayer marks during the upper Moon
meeting even muzon stated that utero
would be a higher rank if daki wasn't
holding him back meaning that he might
even be stronger than gyoko in muzan's
eyes however the most significant
advantage that siblings have over the
upper Moon 5 is that both of them have
to be decapitated simultaneously which
would be pretty much impossible for Yoko
to do alone so if they play their cards
right you threw and daki should be able
to defeat gyoko and take his spot as the
new upper moon five demons okay this
fight turned out pretty interesting but
there are still four more incredible
battles to cover and let's continue with
the one for the upper four title between
gyoko and Han Tengu with his blood demon
art Yoko should be able to easily Dodge
all the attacks upon Tango's clones as
he can just teleport to a different
location each time he is threatened Also
let's not forget that Yoko can also
spawn his own fish monsters to fight for
him although these creatures are not as
strong as on tangu's clones they should
still be really helpful as gyoko could
use them as bait and strike the Clones
when they are not expecting it in the
anime it was said that each of the
Clones is as strong as the upper Moon
demon however given the fact that tandro
nezuko and genya were able to defeat
pretty much all of them they seem to be
much weaker than Kyoko so utilizing his
fish monsters and blood demon art I
think Yoko should be able to handle
hontango's clones and find the main body
however this is where things get hard
for gyoko as as soon as he gets close to
the main body huntenka will merge all of
his clones and transform into his
strongest form zohakuten so hakuten is
incredibly powerful and his strength is
incomparable to Hong tengu's previous
forms even if gyoko transforms into his
final form I just don't see a way he
could contend against this one sister
the only reason tandro managed to kill
the real body was because Missouri
stayed behind to keep zohakuten busy and
since Yoko was all alone in this fight
there's just no way he'd be able to do
it therefore hontanga would win this
Blood battle maintaining his current
rank but now the real challenge awaits
him as if he wants to progress further
through the ranks he'll have to face the
current upper Rank 3 akaza as the upper
Rank 3 akaza is remarkably strong and a
master of hand-to-hand combat which in
combination with his blood demon art
makes him a highly formidable foe during
his life as a demon akaza has fought
against and defeated numerous ashiras
without breaking a sweat and during The
Last Arc in the manga he battled against
both Tundra and giyu two marked demon
Slayers on equal footing based on this
akaza would easily dominate huntengu's
clones toying with them and swiftly
taking them down due to akasa's
overwhelming strength pontengo would
immediately be forced to transform into
his strongest form starting the real
blood battle using his story whose style
and blood demon art akasa easily
counters ohakuten's wide-ranged attacks
he will take his time to enjoy the fight
and then using his compass needle
ability he'll find zohakuten's vital
points and go for the kill however even
after successfully beheading him
zohakuten would just regenerate as the
main body would still be alive this is
where the battle gets difficult for
akaza as he not only has to defend
against sohokatan's attacks but also
find the main body simultaneously but it
gets even harder you see akasa's
abilities allow him to sense killing
intent which he uses to locate and keep
track of his opponents do you see a
problem with this that's right since on
Tengu is a massive coward with no desire
to fight at all akazu wouldn't be able
to sense him the only thing he could do
is just run around and search for him
manually but considering that he also
has to keep an eye on sohokerton and not
die this would pretty much be impossible
no matter how many times a cause of
beheads him so hockatin will just keep
on regenerating giving akaza no time to
search for the main body so in the end
despite all of akaza's efforts this
Blood battle will end in a draw of
course this doesn't mean that hunting is
on the same level of strength as akaza
it's just that due to huntingu's
exceptional circumstances it's very hard
for one single opponent to defeat him
anyway since the battle ended in a draw
akaza will still retain his upper Moon 3
title before we cover the ultimate fight
for the upper rank one title let's first
go over the long-awaited fight between
Doma and akasa this would be an exciting
battle and the hardest one to predict we
arguably never got to see doma's full
strength in the show as he has never
been serious during his fights
furthermore he never really faced an
opponent who would push him to his
limits like the other demon moons did
because of this it's hard to estimate
his actual strength and just how far he
could go however one thing is certain
this would be a really long and
exhausting battle for both demons or
even minor mistakes could cost them
their lives Doma is always faking a
carefree and playful attitude but in her
reality he cannot feel any emotions this
is a big problem for akaza as he
wouldn't be able to sense doma's
fighting Spirit due to this akaza's
compass needle ability would be pretty
much useless which will give Doma an
upper hand another reason why Domo may
have a slight upper hand is because he
always prioritized eating humans to get
stronger especially women who he says
are the most nutritious akaza on the
other hand has vowed never to eat women
which greatly limits him another
interesting thing is that both moons
have completely opposite fighting styles
akaza prefers close combat encounters
due to his Mastery of martial arts at
the same time Doma is more comfortable
at a long range or he can safely use his
abilities to deal lethal damage although
it's pretty much impossible to guess the
winner of this fight based on all the
things we have discussed so far Doma
seems to have higher chances of winning
a conversation that solidifies this
happened in season 3 when kokoshibo told
a Kaza that if he's unhappy with the
current rankings he can always request a
battle with Doma and take his place
however even after being offered this
asaza didn't do it and instead angrily
left the castle I don't know about you
guys but to me the whole conversation
seemed like a Kaza knew he wasn't as
strong as Doma and needed to train more
before challenging him so although this
would probably be the hardest battle in
doma's life he would eventually emerge
Victorious and keep his upper two
ranking and finally the moment you've
all been waiting for it's time for the
ultimate blood battle that will
determine the holder of the upper rank 1
title Doma vs kokushiba kokoshibo is the
highest ranked demon amongst the 12
kizuki second only to The Demon King
himself over his nearly 500 year long
life kokoshipo has battled numerous
demon Slayers and killed multiple
hashiras he has refined his skills to
absolute perfection mastering total
concentration breathing and even the
transparent World considering all this
you may think this would be an easy win
for kokoshiba but underestimating Doma
would be a grave mistake as he won't go
down without a fight although Doma is
much younger than topushivo in a short
period of time he managed to surpass
pretty much every demon and rise to the
upper rank too additionally he was shown
effortlessly defeating many hashira
level Fighters such as kunai and nosuke
Canal and shinobu the battle between
these two would be epic and even a
single attack could decide the winner
domus one advantage in this duel is that
his blood demon art cryokinesis is much
more versatile than kokoshibo's Moon
breathing he's able to perform a bunch
of unique attacks with it like creating
ice shards Frost that is lethal to
inhale and even ice clones of himself
which he claims are as strong as him all
of these different techniques would
definitely keep kokoshiba on his toes as
he'd never know what to expect on the
other hand although kokoshiba's Moon
breathing may not be as versatile as
doma's techniques it's much deadlier and
harder to dodge as he can create
multiple Crescent moons from his Katana
and send them toward opponents however
most importantly kokoshibo has a
transparent World ability allowing him
to easily predict attacks and find
enemies weak spots okay so after all of
this how would this battle actually play
out in the beginning Doma would
definitely be able to keep up with
kokoshibu's attacks fighting toe-to-toe
against him better than kyome and the
other hishira could the two demons would
trade blows but using the transparent
world kokoshiba would avoid any serious
injury on the contrary Doma would take a
lot of serious damage but due to his
regenerative abilities he quickly
recover and continue fighting due to
this the battle would be
actually long and although the power gap
between the two is not that big it's
considerable enough for kokoshivo to
eventually win here therefore he'd keep
his rank as the strongest demon moon
ever click on this video next where we
covered 13 plot holes in Demon Slayer go
on click it